Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Alhamdulillahi khalif al wujoodi min al-adam waja al-nuri min al-zulam wa mukhraj sabri min al-alam wa mulkit taubati al-nadam panashkuru alal masa'ibi kamanashkuru al-ni'am wanusalli ala rasulihilakam lissharaf al-asham wan nur al-atam wal kitab al-mahtam wa kamal in nabiyina wal khatam
Salyadi waladi adam aladi basharadhi aisabnumariam wadda ali baasatihi Ibrahimu alaihis salam shina kara yarfa'u a wa aida baitillah al-Mu'arram.
Fasallallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salam mu'ala adba'ahi khairil umam aladi barakallahu bahim ka fatan nass al-arabamin umwal ajam.
Wa salallahu ala amir al-mu'minin alanza al-bateen waqa idil ghuril muhajalin, ghalib ala kulla ghalib, matluba kulla talip, Mawlana ali ibn Abi Talib
Alhamdulillah, al-ladi anzala ala azdhil kita, walam yaja Allahu aywaja, walhamdulillah, al-ladi lam ya tasid waladan, walam ya kundahu sharikun tilmulk, walam ya kundahu waliyum mina zulli wa kabbir utakbira.
Wa alhamdulillah, al-ladi nahmaduhu, wanas ta'ainuhu, wanas tasiruhu, wanot minu bihi, wanatawakkalu alaih
Wa na rudubillahi min shurui anfusina wa min sayyyati amalina man yaadahillahu palamudillala woman yudlilhu palahadiyala Wa nasharu Allah ilaha illa Allah Wahdahu lasharikalah Wa nasharu Anna Muhammadan Abdullahi wa rasulih Arsalahu Allahu ta'ala bilhudawadeen Alhaq Leozhira wa aladinikulli wa kathabillahi shahida
Wa nashadu anna maulana alibnabi taalib fasihu wa waziru fasallahu alaihim wa ala alaihim wa salimahum tasleeman kasiran kasira.
Allahumma la ilmalana illa ma alamtana inda kaantal alimul Hakeem.
Allahumma alimna bima yanfa'ana.
Wa yanfa'ana bima alamtana.
Allahumma inna na huzubika min al min la yanfa.
Wa min kalbin la yabsha.
Wa min ainim la tadma wa min natsin la tashtaa.
Fa ammata adiyakunu subhana wa ta'ala thikita bihil kareem baadanakhula aa'udubillah immina shaytana regime bismillahur Rahmanur Rahim.
Rabbishrahli sadri wa yasir li amri wahlul qdatamil lisani yafta'u kawli.
Allah umma tabitna aimdal mautibila ilaha illallah walla ummajalna mina lavina amanu amil salehaat wa tawaasa bilhaat wa tawaasa of Sabat amin ya rabbil alami.
Once again, Assalamu Alikum wa Rahmatullah wa barakatuh.
Continuing our flow of conversation, we've discussed in detail the self, we've discussed the theme of Quran, right, those two categories on the website.
Today, inshallah, we'll start a new group of topics that are categorized as, you know, know thy master, because I had know thy self, know thy Quran, and now we're going to look at know thy master.
So in these topics, we will take a closer look at Allah and His various attributes, a better understanding of who Allah is.
And then we'll also look at His relationship and His expectations from us, according to the Quran.
And we'll cover some very interesting topics, like His proof of existence, the concept of His mercy, the concept of Him being...
the whole concept behind creating this universe and then fate and destiny and things like that so I find you know most people find these topics very interesting um now the discussion of Allah it usually begins with the understanding of the word ilah right ilaha illallah so it begins with the understanding of the word ilah in fact the word Allah itself comes from the root word ilah
But in order to properly understand the depth of this word, it's interesting that we first need to understand the Quranic concept of love, right, which is wila.
So, you know, and the Islamic concept of love is very different from the Bollywood and Hollywood concept of love.
So, in order to understand ila, we must first have a clear understanding of love itself
Like the Quranic love.
And then in order to understand love, we need to first understand friendship.
Because love always begins with friendship.
You cannot fall in love with someone unless and until you develop a friendship with that person first.
Real friendships develop into true love.
And it's interesting because if you think about it, we don't need friendship for lust.
This is why today in our society, we see these things like one night stands and casual, meaningless sex.
It's all around us in this society because it's all based on lust.
And it's very confusing sometimes, especially when I talk to kids.
I mean, it becomes very confusing between these terms.
I mean, what is the distinction between friendship, love, lust, all of these things.
But lust, like we've talked about, it stems from this base animal instinct, which is full of the Shawaniya that we studied in the earlier sessions.
And I talked about this at quite length.
And this is something that is related to animals, right?
Because animals don't need to first become friends in order to mate, right?
So I think that gives a good understanding of the difference.
But love always begins with the sentiments of friendship.
I mean the Arabs have this beautiful saying that whenever the plant of love will grow, it will always grow in the soil of friendship.
I really like that saying and I think it's very true.
So before we look at the term ilah we must first look at the various shades of love and before we can do that we must first understand the different types of friendship Quran talks about.
In today's day and age it has become
extremely difficult to create genuine and real friendships, especially for you kids.
Today the world has moved towards virtual friendships like Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, all this kind of stuff.
And today friendships not only require but they're sustained by phones or some other electronic devices.
I mean we have become so enslaved to our phones and our devices that
For us to have like a 15 minute conversation with another person without checking our phones or texting, it's become impossible.
So the more connected we have become to our devices, the less connected we have become with each other, right?
We are no longer able to have that genuine, real connections and conversations with one another.
I mean, if you talk to your parents or your grandparents, I mean, they'll tell you what those conversations used to be like.
right so you know instead of us owning these devices they have started to own us you know our devices are now our Masters and we are its obedient slaves because you can you can actually see this in light the second it go the phone goes ding we have to drop anything and everything we're doing in order to turn to our device right oh who who texted me right so we turn to our devices in that object
Obedience, right?
I hear and I obey.
So it's almost like, you know how, you know how these people who have asthma, they have to take an inhaler every few minutes because they have a problem in breathing?
I literally see that has become pretty much the same things with phones today and Wi-Fi.
I need Wi-Fi.
Is there Wi-Fi in here?
How can there not be Wi-Fi?
So today we gasp for Wi-Fi just as asthma patients gasp for breath.
In fact, the other day I was telling my daughter about the Kaaba and I was talking like maybe we can plan to go to Umrah or something like that.
So I asked her, what would you like to learn about Mecca and the whole Umrah process and all that?
You know what's the first thing she asked me?
All the things she would have asked me?
Do they have Wi-Fi?
as it is you know this is what our lives have been reduced to so anyway so today I want to throw some light on this ironic concept of friendship okay now we can go into this conversation with two different kinds of mindsets we can approach this topic in two ways basically the first is that what kind of friends we should look for like
You know trying to find these qualities and characteristics in our friends or other people That's the first kind of mindset that we can have when we have this conversation But that's a selfish way of looking at this according to the Quran Okay, the correct and the proper way of looking at this conversation is what kind of friend should you and I be to others?
You see?
Not what kind of friends we should have, but rather what kind of friends we should be.
That's the lesson we want to learn from this conversation.
Because when you become the right kind of friend to others, Allah Himself puts the right kind of people in your path.
I mean, that's just, we call it with different names, karma or whatever you want to call it, right?
That's just how it works.
So there are about 10 different words in the Quran for these different kinds and shades of friends.
And each term presents its own nuances in terms of how Allah brings it up in His different verses.
So we'll go through some of these terms and try to understand, you know, in the light of how Allah is using them and basically what we learn from these different nuances about these various kinds of friendships.
So, the first of these words is Wali.
Right?
The first word of friendship that we'll look at is the word Wali.
this word in in the Arabic language it comes from which is a kind of protection so a is someone who takes care of your matters you it is someone who always have has your back basically so a is a friend that in some sense when you when when trouble hits you you know no matter what that kind of trouble it it is you know he's always there to guard you and protect you
It basically handles your situation for you.
So a Wali is used for a friend, but then not just any kind of friend.
You see, it is used for a strong friend that you can always count on to not only get you out of any mess that you are in, but also protect you from getting into trouble in the first place.
And this is why Allah in the Quran calls himself Wali, right?
So there is this
Allah is the wali, the protective friend of the believer.
And what does this protective friend do?
He takes them out of darkness and brings them into light.
And those who disbelieve, their protective friends are who?
It's the shayateen, it's the devil.
He takes them out from light and puts them into darkness.
So, Allah Himself uses the word wali to describe Himself, that Allah is the wali of those who believe.
He is a protective friend to those who believe.
Now, another variation of the same root word is the word mawla.
This is used for that same caring and concerned friend who has the ability to protect you.
But now this person takes an authoritative role in your life.
In other words, when we are 100% convinced that someone truly cares about us, that someone truly has our best interest at heart, we submit to the authority of this person.
Like children submit to their parents, students submit to their teachers.
So in that sense, that authoritative figure who is in that position of protecting becomes the Maula.
Because if we listen to him, he will protect us from getting into trouble.
Or he will help us get out of trouble when we're in it.
So when that person in that position of authority over our affairs, when that person takes that position, he is called Mawla.
You understand?
This is why we say Mawlana Ali.
That's why we add the word Mawla before his name.
And we use that word mullah not only to attest to his authority over our affairs and this is a self-given authority that we have given him authority.
It's not like a dictatorship, you understand?
Because remember, the context is friendship.
So we attest to his authority over our affairs but also to substantiate the fact that we believe him to be our caring and our concerned friend who is there to protect us, whose teachings are there to protect us and keep us out of trouble.
So, we look at him as someone who always has our back, basically.
You know, he's someone whose teachings always have our best interests at heart.
You understand?
So by adding that word Maula before his name, we testify for his Vilaya, his genuine and sincere love, care and concern for us in order to protect us.
Now there's an interesting adjective that the Quran uses for this word wali in a verse, and that word is, that the Quran uses is hameen.
Right?
So let me find this for you.
So wali and hameen.
So imagine you're talking to this guy, right, this believer, and I think every one of us has sort of
face the situation and so you're talking to this guy really nicely and you're trying to explain religion to him and you know Islam is such a good religion and all of that and he's responding back to you with the most aggressive language right you're being kind and respectful to this guy and he's being a complete *** in response right so Ashraf says act with him as a protective friend Wali and Hamim
Continue behaving with him as if you're looking out for him.
In other words, respond in the most gentle way possible, like a protective friend.
But not just that, then he adds the adjective hameen.
The word hameen comes from huma, which means fever.
It is a word that is also used to describe intense heat in the Arabic language.
So in this verse, this word is used to describe the intimacy of friendship.
You know, Hameen is when you are that close with someone that there is heat in your friendship.
There is a closeness, right?
An intimacy in that friendship.
I'm not talking about heat in the romantic sense.
I'm talking about it in the sense that you feel strongly towards someone to the extent that it heats you up in the, you know, makes you all warm inside.
So a Hameem is a friend that when you are in their company you feel all warm and fuzzy inside.
And the Quran is saying that you have to be like that towards who?
Towards someone who is being aggressive towards you.
Someone who's acting like a with you.
So then imagine how are you to be with a believer.
If that is how we are to deal with somebody who's acting in that way with us, then imagine how we are to act with a believer.
And that just sets the context, right?
SubhanAllah.
So just look at the beautiful standards that Quran sets for us as believers.
I mean, it's really incredible.
And then they say Islam is a violent religion, right?
So this is the first kind of friend we're supposed to be with each other, Wali and Hami.
a protective friend the second kind of friend is sadiq the word sadiq comes from siddq which means two things it means sincerity and it means truthfulness right that's that's the meaning of sadq so a sadiq is actually an extremely sincere and truthful friend
So when you are a sadif to someone, what that means is that you are friends with that person for no reason other than a genuine intention of just wanting to be with that person.
You understand?
You're not friends with them because being friends with them will make you feel more popular at school or work, right?
Or being friends with them will make other people think more highly of you.
Or because they are really rich and you want to get some advantage out of that.
Or they're very knowledgeable, so hanging out with them is going to make you look like a scholar or something.
In other words, when you are a sadiq, you have no hidden agenda.
Your friendship has no strings attached.
It's the most genuine and sincere kind of friendship.
You are friends with them just for who they are, not because of the things they own or their social status or nothing artificial or superficial like that.
But if you have a genuine friendship without all of these things, then that is truly Satkaal.
You're going to be there for that person no matter what.
So you can just see, right, that being a Siddiq is not easy.
Having a Siddiq is even more difficult in this day and age.
I mean, it's easy to have people that you can casually chat with or gossip with.
I mean, that's easy.
But having a Sadees is a really, it's very difficult, it's very rare because these are the kinds of friends that never give up on you no matter how many times you fail.
You know, people will, your friends will work with you a few times, one time, twice, three times and at some point they'll be like, you know what?
But a Sadees will never give up no matter how many times you fail, they will always be there.
So that's the first nuance, that's sincerity, right?
The second is truthfulness.
So the Arab had this saying, you know, your friend is someone who speaks the truth to you, who is honest with you.
He's not just someone who's friendly with you.
You know the difference between a friend and being friendly?
A lot of people will be friendly, but they're not your friends.
All those people on your Facebook are not your friends, even if they are friendly with you.
But these people, these
They're completely honest with you.
When you are falling off, they will say, listen, I care about you.
I don't want you to do this because I believe this is going to hurt you.
So you need to stop this.
They're just direct with you, honest with you.
Sadif is not there just to look good and give you that warm and fuzzy feeling that you crave.
He tells you the harsh truth.
The truth that you don't want to hear.
That's why it comes from the root word siddq, which means truthfulness. So now if you are a siddiqu to someone, then whatever it takes, no matter the consequences, you are going to be genuinely honest with that friend. As a siddiqu, you will not simply agree with your friend, knowing very well that the path that they have chosen is going to lead them to their destruction.
And you're not afraid that if you say something to them or they say something to you, the friendship will come to an end. Well, I don't want to say anything because, you know, he might get really upset. That's not a siddiq. Because, I mean, that's a genuine fear. That's why we usually lose our friends, right? I mean, we are honest to our friends and they don't want to hear it. So that's how the friendships end.
but that's not what a siddhir does. And that's what we're learning, that we should be siddhir in life. We'll never give up on our friends, no matter how painful it gets. And we never, and these are not mutually exclusive, right?
So it's not like, oh, I'm going to be a Siddi and I'm not going to be a Wali. The point is that these are all shades. These are like a rainbow. It's like a rainbow with all these different colors. It's one rainbow, but it has all these different shades. So we have to be a Wali and we have to be protective. We have to be caring, concerned, as well as truthful and sincere. So don't look at these as, oh, I like this one. I'm going to stick with this one. No, that's not the idea. Think of it like a rainbow.
it all has to come together to be the perfect friend so you have to be all these nine ten things in order to be qualified from the Quranic perspective as the perfect friend now interestingly if we look at this word in the Quranic context it's interesting how this word is used Allah says that on the day of judgment there are some people who will find themselves on the wrong side of the fence
These are people who are heading towards hellfire. So Allah, when he talks about them in the Quran, he says, let me see. So Allah says about them in the Quran that . So these people that are about to enter hellfire, they're saying, it's not our fault that we're going to hell. It's not our fault that we are in trouble on this day of judgment. We're here because of these other criminals who misled us.
so it's their fault you know these evil people misled us and Allah describes you know what they say they say we have nobody on our side today to make a case for us so is someone who likes you and when you get into trouble they stand in the way and say no no no no he's good he's okay
He's with me, right? Like imagine you're in trouble with the principal and your teacher steps in and says, no, no, no, she's a good girl. She's a good student. Don't worry about it. You know, I'll take care of her. You know, that's Shifaa. So these people are saying, today nobody's coming to back us up. Nobody had our back today. And then they say, Walaa Sadeep in Hamin. Now this is the only time the word Sadeep is used like this directly in the Quran.
they say today we have no true sincere and honest and truthful friends we have no truthful sincere friends that are close to us today we have no loving friends today and by saying this Allah is reminding us that the converse is also true you see if people on the wrong side are complaining that they have no close friends
on this day that means the people on the right side of judgment day you know the ones going to heaven they will actually have close friends to back them up and it is because of their close friends that that's where they're heading right and this is why who is the ultimate Sadiq and Hameen that you know that us that believers have access to we have the Shafa of Rasulullah right inshallah may Allah qualify us all for that
But what are these disbelievers or people of hellfire complaining about? That on this day, they don't have a what? A Sadiq. Because in the world, when someone would give them a sincere and honest advice, they would turn them down. You see? They would mock them. They would make fun of them, ridicule them. They would break their friendships with them.
But today, these same people are wishing that they had those Sadiq in Hameen. You see? And the scope of this is quite broad. I mean, look at... We reject the hierarchy of the elders because of what they're saying, based on what we think is happening or the...
the true or false propaganda that we receive and things like that. But it doesn't change the fact that there's still Sadiq and I mean what they're saying is for our benefit. What they're saying is the true honest truth. You know we...
We break our allegiance with them or we break our ties with them based on certain things or actions that we see happening or things like that. But that doesn't change the fact about what they're saying. They're still being sadiq to us. They're giving us the sincere, honest truth about what is going to protect us. And on the day of judgment, the Ayah says that there will be people who will search for them and ask for them and complain about not having them. But something really to think about.
And the point and the lesson is that we don't be among these people. So if you have a true Siddip in your life, if somebody fits this profile in your life, hold on to them and stick with them no matter how harsh and painful their truth feels. Because usually they're going to tell you something you don't want to do or they're going to stop you from something that you do want to do. So that's how you can identify a Siddip.
Because in the long run, they will turn out to be your best friends in the Akha. So that's Siddiq, right? The third term that I want to look at is this term Sahib. This is a very comprehensive word in the Quran that is used for friend. Sahib could be used in the more casual sense.
You know, for people that you are sitting next to in a train or a bus during a journey. So if you're on a train traveling to a destination and there's this guy sitting next to you for the next four hours, technically he can be called your Sahib. Right? So this word can be used for some very casual acquaintance. But then, interestingly, if you spend a lifetime with someone, that person is also your Sahib because it means companion.
But whether you look at it short term or long term, there is one thing that is generally common for someone to qualify as a Sahib. A Sahib is someone who always means well for you. They will always want something good for you.
So if there is a problem, they will always try to help you in whatever capacity they can.
And the more they know you,
The more they possess the ability to help you, the more genuinely concerned they are going to be for you. You see? This is why one of the names of RasulAllah in the Quran is Sahib. Allah uses this word Sahib for RasulAllah, right? Wama sahib ukum bi majnun Your companion is not insane. And check this out, right? People of Mecca are calling him insane.
And what is Allah saying? This companion of yours, this companion, this man who is actually genuinely concerned about you, who's actually concerned about your well-being, who cares about you, he's not insane. He didn't say my messenger is not insane, my prophet is not insane. Right?
He didn't say the one I sent is not insane, the one I love the most is not insane. I mean, this is the greatest man who ever walked the face of this earth, right? And they're calling him insane. But look how Allah is explaining his position to them. He doesn't say that this amazing man is not insane. No, He says your companion, the one who genuinely cares for you is not insane.
So that's the Balara of Quran. I mean, we don't really pick these things up when we're reciting it or going through translations, but the ancient atoms did. And it is statements like these, like, look at the size of the statement, right? But this one statement converted so many people because they could see the depth of what is being said here. And they could realize that human beings cannot talk like this. So the takeaway for us is that
we need to learn to interact as ashab see this is and not just Rasulullah was called Sahib even what were the companions called ashab right same same word because they also genuinely cared about Rasulullah they also genuinely did everything they could to help him so what we need to learn is to interact with each other as ashab as companions right this is again
something that is gradually disappearing at a societal level you know the concept of Suhba it works at an individual level but it also works at a societal level because remember it's long term and short term right the companions during the time of the prophet they celebrated normality you know they did not create fake standards of living today we don't care about this kind of companionship you know if I buy an expensive phone
You know, I will make sure I flash it in your face every five seconds. Oh, you don't have, you still have an iPhone 6? Poor guy. It's okay, don't worry, I'll still hang out with you. You know, but only when we're alone, because I don't want to be seen with you when you're, you know, iPhone 5 or whatever. So that goes against the whole concept of being aside. It's not that I shouldn't, I cannot own a phone.
But it's just about not flashing it in the face of people who I know will start feeling bad about it. Because as a Sahib, I'm supposed to always be concerned about my companion's feelings. And I'm not going to go out of my way to show off just to make him feel inferior. So you know what I mean? So it's not that you cannot have good stuff. That's not what it's being... The idea is not that.
You know, oh, I bought this cheap bag, you know, but this whole thing, it's just, it's just Gucci, you know, I just got it on a sale for like 800,000. You know, so that shows you're not concerned about your companion's feelings. Especially if you know that, you know, he or she could not afford it. I said he, but I hope no, he is not buying Guccis, but who knows. Anyway, so it's just my point is that it's a very delicate term in that respect.
Okay, so that was Sahid. This is pretty interesting, right? The way of all these different shades of friendship. So we have to be a Wali and we have to be a Siddif and we have to be a Sahid. Now the next one is Walija. This term occurs once in the Quran, Walija.
which comes from the verb in Arabic and it means to penetrate deeply right Allah says Allah knows what goes into the Earth and what comes out of it so is a friend who is all up basically he's all up in your business they know all about what is going on in your life and they are deeply involved in your Affairs
And you trust this person so much that you can share anything and everything with them. And you don't just share it at an information level, they're actually involved in your life on a day-to-day basis. Now, this is a very special kind of friendship. It's not your typical friendship. It's not someone you are nice to or you sometimes hang out with or you text back and forth. This is a very, very close kind of friendship.
And it's very rare to find such a friend in this day and age. I mean, you know, this is someone that you can trust with your bank account. This is someone you can trust with your children. This is someone you can trust with all your gold and jewelry without a second thought. You know, you can trust them in any affair of your life. So these are people that you give signed blank checks to.
because you're traveling for a month and you know I'm traveling for a month could you please write out these checks for my bills or whatever and you don't have to think twice about it you're not wanted at all and that's why this kind of friendship is very reckoning now it's interesting how Allah uses this word in the Quran and and in fact he makes it a condition that you can only have this level of friendship with three specific entities
right so what does walija mean you know a deep penetrating friendship right so Allah says do you think that you shall be left alone while Allah has not yet tested them among you you know who have made an effort and thought and things like that
and who have not taken walija besides Allah His messenger and the believers now what does that mean Allah is calling Himself a walij to us why is that you and I will go through trials in our lives
and Allah will test to see how deeply Allah's love and His commands have penetrated your most important personal affairs what is His role in your family decisions what is His role in your personal decisions in the kind of financial decisions you make the kind of business decisions you make you know the kind of career and education decisions you make what is His role in your life
you know how deeply has Allah's love penetrated your life that's a one each you know is he one each to you do you have that kind of friendship with Allah or not right so that's that's the that's the tone of the ayah then he added the messenger salallahu alaihi wa salam like he how much do you consult the legacy of your prophet in the most personal matters of your life
When you and I are having trouble in life, how much do we consult the life and the seerah of the Prophet and his example? Now when you and I are facing doubts and trouble in Islam, how much do we consult the advice of Rasulullah? How deeply involved is he in our most intimate matters? Right?
see today we talk about the Sunnah of the messenger you know we celebrate and we emphasize the most outwardly aspects of the Sunnah there's the Sunnah of prayer there's the Sunnah of keeping a beard Sunnah of you know being the first to say Salam you know the Sunnah of these mannerisms and these etiquettes that we have learned from our beloved messengers and it's there we do that but in most aspects these are still public and outward facing
But the most intimate matters of our lives, when it comes to the most private internal matters, like should I enter this financial transaction? You know, should I buy these types of clothes? Should I go out with these kinds of friends to this kind of place? Should I be involved in the kinds of things they're doing? So that's when this question becomes important. Like, have I involved the messenger in those decisions?
that have to do with my most private affairs I mean where is the Sunnah in those matters right even even in the way we talk with each other I mean in our Ahlaq in the way we carry ourselves do we follow the Prophet I mean just look at the way we talk to each other today I mean it's so messed up right there's no Sunnah in it and that's an outward form of Sunnah today there's no respect for the elders there's no humility in mutual conversations with each other
or when interacting with each other, right? Allah is telling us in the Quran that we are supposed to talk respectfully and kindly and as a protective friend to our enemies, you know, . But we do not even behave that way with each other. I mean the second we disagree about something, look what happens, right? We start beating them with evidence, we curse them out, we mock them.
even in something as simple as a conversation there is a major deviation from the Sunnah Rasulullah his Seerah has not penetrated our lives at all it hasn't penetrated our conversations right so that's the second one and then he says um you know and then finally he includes the believers in other words if you find Allah
intimately connected in your life and you find the teachings of the Prophet intimately connected in your life, then Allah will give you the best kinds of believers in your life. He will give you the gift of those kinds of special friends that you can trust to the depth of your personal lives. And what a gift it is to have because trust is something that has completely disappeared in our times, right?
We cannot trust anybody today. We cannot trust the people we work with. We cannot trust our closest friends. That kind of trust is gone. The walija kind of trust is gone. And Allah is giving us the secret to finding those kind of friends. If you let Allah in your lives, if you let the messenger in your life, then the next step will be that Allah will give you the gift of true believers. And we will be able to trust like that. That is another freedom that Allah gives us.
There's one thing for a person to be trustworthy and then for us to have that freedom to be able to trust like that.
So that's, it's a amazing gift, right?
Another kind of friendship is this type of friendship is bhitana, which comes from bhatan.
Now what does bhatan mean?
It means stomach.
So bhitana is actually a friend who keeps your secrets.
So the other one was a Walija, who was involved in all your personal matters.
This one keeps and protects your secrets.
And remember, this is all inclusive, right?
So the Wali should be a Sahib, the Sahib should be a Siddih, and a Walija and a Vitana.
So it's all coming together.
So when you tell this person about something personal that happened today in your life, you can trust them to take the secret to their graves.
Which is not, again, something that is rare today, right?
What happens when you tell a friend a secret today?
You tell them not to say it to anyone and what happens?
They put you on speaker and they start texting their friends, Hey, listen up.
Don't tell anyone, but you know what?
And don't tell them because it's a secret.
Shh.
And then they do that thing to the next one and the next one and the next one.
So that's not a bitana.
We all have friends who have a very light stomach.
And they just cannot keep a secret.
And the lesson here is that we should not be that way.
And now the context of this verse is interesting because it's a very specific context.
you know Allah says so you know this this verse is actually in the context of the Battle of Uhad in Surah Al-Imraham for those of you who have studied the Seerah you know that the Battle of Uhad is a very difficult military situation for the Muslims right you know there are all these different communities that would live in that lived in Medina Christians Jews all of them right and some of them
You know, they knew are cooperating with the disbelievers because it's all family members, right?
You know, one person in the family converted and became Muslim.
The remaining are Jews and all Christians or things like that.
So in that context, in this context of this Battle of Fahad Allah saying, don't tell your secrets to your Jewish and Christian friends because you don't know who's going to spy on you in the state of war.
Be careful because a lot of them are not going to leave any stone unturned and they will want to harm you because it's battle.
they want to win so Allah is not talking about everyone right he's talking about those who have this propensity who have this potential to harm you like this so just be on the careful side in that context so again the context of this verse is a state of war right a tense situation where leaking intelligence could cause lies
You know so one might casually talk and say that yeah you know I met the Prophet today and he's going to be at this place under that tree at this time.
Now for you it might be a not big deal but for someone who's trying to assassinate the messenger this information is gold.
Or maybe that person then shares that secret with somebody else and then that person tries to harm it.
So it can perpetuate like that.
So what Allah is saying is that keep your close secrets to the closest among you.
that's the context of this verse um but what we learn from this verse is the description of what this friendship is supposed to mean like so there's another flavor or another shade of this friendship that we learn which is the Tana a friend who knows your deepest and darkest secret right so that's the Tana next one is Khalil right and it's it's the most beautiful word that is used for a friend in the Quran Khalil and this word Khalil it comes from
which is again a very comprehensive word because one of you know you you hear this word again when we talk about love because is also a form of love um but but in this context what I want you to understand is that uh and what will help you understand is that this another word that comes from the same root which is you know and some of you know what this means right is fluffing
So Khilal is when something goes into or in between something else.
Like when you floss, you put that thread in between your teeth.
That is Khilal in Arabic.
So Khilal is someone whose friendship penetrates deeply in your heart.
Walija was somebody who penetrates deeply into your affairs in terms of trust.
Khaleel is someone whose friendship penetrates deeply within your heart this is like this is very you know this shade is very mixed with love you know you love someone that deeply that's a Khaleel you have this deep-seated love for this person that that you constantly think about this person they put it in those terms you know this Khaleel is the one that you constantly think about that you constantly miss them when you're not with them that's a Khaleel
That's how you know that this person is a Khalil.
You're always thinking about them.
And you wish that you were with them right at this moment.
That kind of a friend is a Khalil.
This is again a very rare kind of friendship.
And this is the kind of friendship that Allah had with Ibrahim , right?
Allah took Ibrahim is a Khalil.
So it's not just, you know, when Allah says, uses the word Khalil for , it's not
it's not just like we think about friendship it's a very different kind of friendship so and Allah uses the word Khaleel in very interesting ways in the Quran you know sometimes in very scary ways and this is something that we have to really take seriously so let's look at this verse right Allah says
you know believers spend from that which we have provided for you you know help others or in the way of Allah before a day comes when there will be no bargaining yawmun la bayaun no bargaining wala khullatun there's going to be no friendships wala shafa'a and there's going to be no nobody to have your back right and in another verse he says um al akhillahu yawma izan baadu hum libaadin adu illal muttaqeen
that really close friends look at this right now Khaleel what did I say Khaleel was this is not just any ordinary friendship right it's a very deeply deep seated love that you have for your friend that's a Khaleel and Allah is saying that these close friends who have so much love for each other Akhla which is the plural of Khaleel Allah says that really really close and intimate friends who are extremely close to each other in this world
When the day of judgment comes, they turn into each other's enemies.
And the only exception that he puts there is mutta'een, the pious ones.
And grammatically, it's a very strong kind of exception, which means that the only possible exception to that is people who protected themselves from making the wrong kinds of friends, from choosing the wrong kinds of khaleel.
you know everyone else that we think you know today we have all these best best you know bestest friends and God knows what right but you know but but all these kinds of friends as in you know over here in the Americas they say like that's my dog I mean that that kind of friends on Judgment Day that's not he's no longer going to be your dog right so in other words make friends based on how conscious they are of Allah
how conscious they are and how responsible they are with their religion I mean don't let the wrong kinds of friends be your Khalil you understand because when the day of judgment comes it's a very scary situation right and these wrongdoers the Quran talks about it like what they say and what it says is let me see there's this verse in which he says
You know the word Sabeel it means generally a path right which is a in Arabic especially in ancient Arabic it's a very beautiful linguistic illustration of a lifestyle right so the path is the path of life basically you know if this person says if I only had chosen the lifestyle of the messenger
I would not be in this mess today right and this is a very powerful verse in the Quran because if you look at the next ayah it says this is really interesting I mean I find this really interesting you know and I really don't know if there's any other verse in the Quran that has more despair in it than this one
because it combines two words of regret ya wailata laitani I mean this is exaggerated hasa you know because you know just laitani is an exaggerated form of hasara waila sorry and then after that it's laitani to describe even more hasara even more despair even more regret right so it's like regret on top of regret so now what is this about and what is he saying
what's so interesting it's not it's not doesn't mention a name it says fulanan you know in Urdu we say oh right like we don't we don't use an actual name we just say you know that person and make it anonymous and what's so interesting is that this verse is actually saying I wish I did not take so and so as my friend fulan fulanan
Now tell me something, Khalil is someone that you have a lot of love for, isn't it?
And if you have so much love for this person, you would at least know their name, wouldn't you?
But judgment day comes along and you have so much regret on top of regret and so much hate fills your heart because of the path that this person has put you on that you cannot even remember his name.
So the verse says, Fulanan Khalila.
I mean this is the level of regret that this person has so you can see that in itself as beautiful as it may be but if you choose the wrong person to be a it could end you up you know it could end up in you could end up in really regretful things okay so that's a but it's interesting how the Quran takes such a beautiful meaning word and then shows you shows you that how you could choose the wrong person
up you know for that position basically next word Rafiq now the word Rafiq in Arabic it comes from Rifka or Rif and what it means is comfort so you know Mirfika these are the pillows that you place behind your back when you know when it's hurting and also the small cushions on the couch they're also called Mirfaq
because you lean on them and they take the pressure off your back and they help you relax, right?
So Rafiq is a friend that when you are stressed out, when you are in serious trouble, when you're going through a difficult time, you turn to them for comfort.
That's Rafiq.
They're like a pillow that you can lean on at any time and find comfort in their company.
And then people who are reclining are they sitting formally or informally?
Always informal, right?
So they're relaxed.
So this is a friend
that you don't have to act in a certain way with or behave in a certain way.
You don't have to walk on eggshells with this person.
You can just be yourself.
If you feel like being happy, good, evil, you know, whatever, whatever you want to say, you can say and without being judged, without the fear of being judged or, you know, somebody taking that and holding that against you for the future.
And this is again, oh my god, such a...
You know, if you have someone who fits this profile, all these words,
You should really do Sijda and do a Shukrana to Allah for giving you such a friend because such a friend is so rare and you need to just cherish this friend like nothing else.
Just look at the qualities of these friends, right?
And you can only appreciate all of this if you have seen the inverse or experienced the inverse in your life.
If there are people that you have or had in your life that you have to walk on eggshells with, then you can really appreciate a Rafiq when you find one.
So that's a Rafiq, somebody that your soul makes you that comfortable.
Now in terms of usage, it's beautiful.
Allah says in Surah Nisa, here this one, right?
right those those who obey Allah and obey the Prophet they will receive special gifts special favors from Allah and what are those what is that special gift that they will be counted among the elite categories they will find comfort in the company of prophets those who did righteous deeds
Those who gave up martyrs, who gave up their life in the way of Allah, right?
And the righteous.
The truthful, the martyrs, and the righteous.
And he ends the verse by saying ...
And what an awesome group of comforting friends these people are.
Allah praising these four categories.
...
What an awesome group of comforting friends to be amongst.
Can you imagine being in the company of Rasulullah and not feeling nervous?
Can you imagine being comfortable around Maulana Ali, around the Imams, right?
Subhanallah.
So Rafiq is another kind of friend who we should all strive to be like, right?
A very comforting friend.
Okay, two more.
Let's get through this.
Next one, Fareem.
now this Kareem is a very cool type of friend Kareem is actually used in Arabic for a rope that is used to hold two camels together you know when two camels are standing side by side and you tie them with one single rope that rope is called Kareem is someone who is always side by side with you he's joined to the hip as they say you know one moves the other moves the other is forced to move they're always moving together
so your Qareen is the friend that you are always hanging out with you're always on the phone with you're always on whatsapp with you know you're constantly you know putting likes on their Facebook they put a picture of a donkey and you put like a like on it that's a Qareen you know you're constantly with this person when you're happy he or she becomes happy when he or she is sad you become sad that's a Qareen
Because you move together.
You see, you're tied together.
And Arim is also somebody that you have a lot in common with.
Very compatible.
Because you cannot tie two camels together where one is very tall and the other is very short, right?
It wouldn't work.
Right?
You cannot tie two camels together in which one is really fast and the other is really slow.
Wouldn't work.
So a Qareen is someone that you pretty much, you're very compatible with.
You pretty much share a brain and a heart with.
You think like them, you feel like them.
You know, they think like you, they feel like you.
So that kind of relationship is Qareen.
Now, interestingly, Qareen can also mean people of the same community.
Like we are all a Qareen right now.
right in the sense that we're all tied together by the same rope of the session right we're all of the same mindset right as a Jamaat as Sulaimanis we are tied together by the rope of Abdi Sharif so you see so it can be used in that broad sense as well we all belong to the same creed so in that respect we're all Khalim we'll all move together and and like Khalif
you know Quran presents this word in a very scary way as well so if you look at in Surah Safat let me share this with you yeah this one right okay so in Surah Safat Allah talks about some of us who may Allah make all of us from that but basically as a group some members of the group they make it to Jannah and we
and in there we inquire about other peoples in our families and communities right so that's this conversation that's the context of these verses and then they turn to each other and they start questioning each other see one of them a speaker within that group they say indeed I used to have this companion this this person that I was really compatible with
and you know he used to ask me he used to mock me he used to make fun of me in the life and you know and even though he was a friend and we always are now together and we did everything together he would always make fun of my religion and he would say you know are you among the believers are you one of those who testify are you among these idiots who call themselves Muslims
I mean are you among those fools who say that when we die and we become dust and bones we shall receive reward and punishment are you among those fools in response it will be said to them this guy is questioning about this friend who used to mock him right and so the other members are going to say
They said look down.
Have you looked down?
Have you looked at the other category of Hellfire?
And so he looks down and he sees that person in the midst of Hellfire.
So may Allah protect us from being one of them.
So the point of this is be careful who you choose as your Qareen.
Your Qareen can make you a shining star.
or a kareem can destroy you right so be very careful who you constantly hang out with in fact there's another verse what is it .....
and whoever turns away from the remembrance of the intensely merciful right whoever turns no we shall appoint for him a shaan and he is going to be a to him right so this is Allah telling us that you know if you turn away from the remembrance of Allah if you disregard Allah if you reject Allah
despite all the evidence despite everything that he has done for you given you shown you all of that if you still turn away from him he is going to as a punishment give you a Qareen and what that Qareen is going to be it's going to be Shaita you will end up hanging out with these kind of people all your the rest of your life right so that's Qareen again I want to
compare this with Khalil you know what a beautiful word Khalil is what a beautiful word Qareen is but then look how Allah is using it in the Quran right it's very interesting and last one um okay so so far we've looked at the good friends that the Quran describes even when used in a bad in a negative context but Khazul is something that is like bad through and through a bad friend
So the Quran also talks about bad friends.
And the word he uses to describe these evil friends is Khazul.
Now, the word Khadala in Arabic, it's close to the meaning of Khada, which means deception.
So Kharul is a friend who will only act like your friend until the moment of truth arrives.
And then you see his true colors.
So they will be with you, you know,
while they were with you they're just like you and they're right by your side you know they help you they're all of these things they pretend to be a Siddiq or Walija and all of these things right when times are convenient they always hang out with you so they were your Qareen but then when time became tough all of a sudden they disappear on you so the Khazul is the one that you will that will reveal
himself or herself in times of difficulty or at the final moment.
You know, you were relying on them to be there for you and then they are nowhere to be found.
This is the kind of friend that is called a Khadul and it is an extremely dangerous friend, right?
You can see why, right?
Because if he's gonna or she's gonna pretend to be your all of these other things, Siddi, Sahib, you know, Rafi, Khalil, all of these things and you're like, oh my God, this is like
But then, right at the moment you find out that this person turns out to be a Khadul.
And, you know, some of us can even relate.
We've gone through some of these experiences.
And it's .
I mean, so this is the point of this word Khadul, it's not just any ordinary deception.
It has to do with extreme kind of deception.
You know, an extremely disappointing friend who leaves you hanging at the worst possible time.
you know this is the walija that you trusted with all your gold and jewelry you wrote him a blank check and the next morning gone this type of deception is hazul and it takes years of consistent effort to hazulify someone right and this is actually the description of Shaytan in the Quran
Shaytaan is described as Khazul because and what is his ultimate deception to prevent us from the remembrance of Allah that's his game to distract us and divert our attention towards dunya so Quran says right
Shaitaan is a Khazool to human beings.
Why is Allah saying that?
Because man is he going to act like your friend in this life.
He is going to be your best friend, your Rafiq, your Khaleel, all of that stuff and he's going to get you into things that you do not want to be in and he will convince you that those things are good for you and they're all for your entertainment and this is the you know forget
Islam and Allah and all that evolution.
Don't reject your forefather monkeys just for this religion.
This is a Khazul.
He will make you watch.
He will put you on a path to watching movies and just enjoying filth.
He will make you buy stuff.
He will make you go places.
He will say things and you will build the wrong kinds of friendships.
All of it.
and you will think man this is so good I'm living it up this is because when the day of judgment comes this guy is nowhere to be found and when on day of judgment when you complain about him he'll be like hey hey hey wow I'm not an author I was never an authority over you and you were never an authority over me you know don't don't complain I
I did not have any authority over you I suggested all of these things to you but you're the one who did it I didn't put a gun to your head right you were the one who chose to do all of these things so now don't blame me blame your own self for the situation that you're in
So you know what?
Look, what's done is done.
You did whatever you did.
I told you.
Now let's just enjoy the barbecue together.
This is Khadun.
That's what's going to happen on Judgment Day.
So you can see how dangerous this is, right?
And it builds with small things.
And that's the question we have to ask ourselves.
Are we these kind of people?
Are we the kind of friends who abandon our friends in their time of need?
Oh, you called?
Oh, I didn't know.
My phone was not even charged.
It was dead.
I just saw my phone.
It was like, oh man, I wish I'd-- you knew he called.
You were just kazuling it.
But you see my point.
So don't be that kind of friend.
If you're going to be a friend with someone, be a reliable person, right?
Reliability is an extremely important quality in friendship, and especially in difficult times.
And not being reliable is one of the easiest ways to lose friends.
You must have some really good friends in your life and you do not want to mess that up because friendship is so rare today.
So these are the different kinds of friendships that the Quran talks about which gives us a really good understanding of the kind of friends we should be.
Like I said in the beginning,
You can look at this two ways.
You can make a list of your friend and say, Rafiq, no.
Khalil, no.
Okay, sorry, you can't be my friend.
You're missing these qualities.
You can do that and just eliminate your friends based on these qualities.
Or you can look at it the other way and say, okay, let me look at myself and say, am I all of these things to my friends or not?
And where do I lack?
Do I need to be a better Khalil?
Do I need to be a better Rafiq?
Do I need to be, you know.
turn ourselves into this perfect friend that the Quran portrays and again see friendship if you understood anything about these words friendships are not about being good it's not about being liked right because that's usually today what friendships what dictates you know what governs friendships right to be liked I want to be cool I want to be liked I want to be loved
and if you really understand the meanings of these words that we talked about today have nothing to do with like you could be the most hated person to your friend and still be the best friend to them right so it's really interesting how the Quranic perception of friendship you know versus the societal concept of friendship but I hope anyway I think this is really I hope this helps you in
setting the grounds because this friendship because you will see right it is this kind of person this kind of friend that you fall in love with so you can see how this friendship leads towards love right if somebody had these qualities that's the person you're going to love right and who has these amazing qualities greater than Allah which then leads to the conversation of ila so I hope
You know, that was the idea of bringing this up at this point.
Okay, so let's....................